[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
jeudi 8 février voici le programme de ce
soir depuis l'arrivée de la fibre à
Montini le Bretonneux les habitants ne
rencontrent que des problèmes faute de
place dans les armoires les technicien
débranche des fils pour en connecter
d'autres face à cette situation le maire
de la commune tente de trouver des
solutions elle a 45 ans elle habite à
noisil-lereroi et elle a remporté le
concours du meilleur pâtissier sur M6
Julia Wilner nous ouvre les portes de sa
cuisine elle nous raconte comment elle a
rejoint cette aventure le jeudi comme
d'habitude nous vous donnerons nos idées
de sortie pour le weekend au programme
de ce soir un festival de théâtre mais
aussi le premier village à vous les jeux
de SaintQuentin en Eveline nous déc
couvrirons également la pratique du
football sur table sans oublier l'invité
du 78 en deuxème partie d'émission nous
parlerons d'un fait de plus en plus
courant les trottinettes électriques qui
prennent feu quels sont les risques les
risques comment l'éviter le lieutenant
colonel Sébastien Frémont du service
d'incendie et de secours des Yvelines
répondra à nos questions voilà le
programme de ce soir bienvenue dans
votre 78 tout de suite on fait le point
sur les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les
yvlines
et c'est avec vous Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir mathine Bruno Le Maire
le ministre de l'Économie a annoncé
auprès du quotidien les écho que l'État
viendrait en aide à l'entreprise Athos
fortement endettée oui Mathilde
l'entreprise informatique dont l'un des
laboratoires est au clés sous-bois
possède une dette de près de 5 milliards
d'euros un montant qui a augmenté en
raison des investissements risqué d'Atos
aujourd'hui l'entreprise n'arrive pas à
la rembourser Bruno Le Maire a déclaré
je cite nous ne laisseront pas tomber
les activités industrielles d'Atos qui
représentent des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois l'état utilisera tous les
moyens à sa disposition pour préserver
les activités stratégiques et alors
pourquoi l'État est-il prêt à venir au
secours d'Atos et bien Mathilde car le
gouvernement veut éviter
l'investissement de partenaires
étrangers dans cette industrie française
atos est une entreprise stratégique de
l'économie et de la défense depuis 1997
elle est aussi un leader dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité et assura la
sécurité informatique des Jeux
olympiques de Paris justement en parlant
des Jeux olympiques de Paris les 5084
médailles olympiques et parallympique de
Paris 2024 ont été dévoilé par le comité
d'organisation et elle possède un petit
détail inattendu oui dessiné par le
joiler chôé et fabriqué par la Monnaie
de Paris les médailles comporteront un
authentique morceau de la tour effffel
côté face il y sera gravé la flamme
emblème des jeux le côté pile lui répond
à un cahier des charges du Comité
olympique on y retrouve la DESS de la
victoire Athena nické le stade
panathenaï et l'Acropole mais
spécialement pour Paris 2024 une tour
Effel figure aussi en arrière-plan pour
les médailles paralympiques le joiler a
choisi choisi une vue en contreprolongée
sur sous la Tour Effel les mots Paris et
2024 sont également écrits en braille en
hommage au français Louis Braille on
c'est pas pour lancer des fleurs à la
France mais ces médailles elles sont
très bellesou sont plutôt jolies oui
toujours en sport la Région île-de-fance
veut soutenir la rénovation énergétique
de certains équipements sportifs oui
c'est ce qui a été annoncé ce mardi 6
février à la piscine Jean-François Henri
de Chatou la région a présenté un
dispositif pour financer les études
thermiques à hauteur de 50000 € pour les
travaux jusqu'à 450000 € pour rappel la
région bénéficie de plus de 45000 lieux
45000 lieux de pratiques sportives parmi
eux il y a des piscines des patinoires
ou encore des gymnases des équipements
vulnérables contenu de l'augmentation du
prix des énergies parmi les projets
soutenus par la région l'installation de
panneaux photovoltaïques sur toiture
alimentant la piscine en électricité au
total les économies d'énergie
enregistrées seraient de l'ordre de 30
%. enfin on termine avec une information
trafic attention demain soir c'est le
début des vacances scolaires pour la
zone C les routes risquent d'être plus
encombrées oui pour ce premier weekend
vous l'avez dit des vacances d'hiver les
vacanciers seront nombreux dans le sens
des départs des difficultés de
circulation sont attendu au départ de
l'Île-de-France ce vendredi il est
conseillé de quitter ou de traverser la
région avant 14h à contrario samedi et
dimanche tous les voyants sont au vert
en Île-de-France pour le moment bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une actualité qui vous a fait
réagir n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78
news coupure internet débranchement
problème d'installation la mise en place
de la fibre est devenue un véritable
casse-tête à Montini le Bretonneux SFR
Orange BCK Telecom Free les opérateurs
commerciaux se renvoient à la balle et 3
ans en 3 ans plus de 170 plaintes ont
été déposées par les habitants face à
cette situation le maire de la commune
tente de trouver des solutions Patrick
jacqu de dismud et Julien Leroi sont le
reportage de Patrick Jacques de dismud
et Julien Leroi moi je pense que
n'importe qui peut l'ouvrir non enfin
bon mais tout tout est arraché là tout
est arraché Jean-Gabriel Fournier est un
client désabusé depuis l'année dernière
cet inimentin subit des interruptions de
connexion régulière lié à la fibre
optique assuré aujourd'hui par
l'opérateur SFR via sa filiale XP fibre
l'infrastructure subit fréquemment des
pannes longues tout comme cet habitant
des abonnés ont déposé plus de 170
plaintes auprès de la commune entre 2020
et 2023 un sentiment d'impuissance face
au service clients des fournisseurs Free
Orange BCK Télécom ou SFR chacun se
rejette la responsabilité et facture
malgré tout les utilisateurs qu joue
avec un voyant qui s'éteint tout de
suite je fonce à l'armoire et
généralement je vois un technicien alors
le technicien c'est pas des gens ni ncfr
ni d'orange c'est des sous-traitants
donc et là eu ah ben vous savez moi on
me demande de brancher cinq personnes
j'ai que qu quatre emplacements ben j'en
branche un au hasard et j'en mets un
pourquoi parce que dès qu'ils sont dès
qu'il a une connexion tout de suite ils
sont tarifés bien que le réseau ne
dépende pas de la commune Montini le
Bretonneux se mobilise pour palier le
vandalisme elle décide d'installer en
2022 des antivol sur la dizaine
d'armoires les plus touchées pour y
accéder le technicien est contraint de
venir récupérer la clé auprès de la
police municipale mais aujourd'hui plus
de 50 cadenas ont été fracturés nous
savons que nous avons plein de salariés
par exemple qui sont en télétravail qui
ont besoin de pouvoir travailler depuis
chez eux nous avons énormément de
familles d'enfants qui ont besoin
d'avoir un accès à Internet et donc il
est absolument inimaginable et
intolérable qu'aujourd'hui en 2024
l'année olympique nous n'ayons pas de
solution et que nous ayons un opérateur
qui soit en incapacité de répondre à
tous ces problèmes qui sont posés sur la
vie une inquiétude grandissante pour la
commune et ses administrés le réseau
ADSL devrait disparaître à partir de
2025 au profit de la fibre optique de
quoi laisser craindre les difficultés
supplémentaires pour les abonnés si
aucune réponse n'est
apportée en décembre dernier
l'ivelinoise Julia Vilner remportait le
concours du meilleur pâtissier sur M6 à
la la base cette habitante de
noisillereroi ne faisait de la
pâtisserie que pour ses enfants mais
elle a rapidement dû répondre aux
sollicitations de ses amis et de ses
connaissances c'est grâce aux réseaux
sociaux qu'elle a été repérée par la
fameuse émission Mélanie poket et
Gabrielle Gontier sont partis à sa
rencontre comment ça a commencé cette
aventure pour vous c'était assez
incroyable en fait je pense que c'est le
destin donc j'avais une petite page
Instagram parce que j'aimais bien faire
des gâteau le weekend pour des amis et
donc souvent bah je prenais des photos
et je les mettais sur sur mon mur
j'aiété contacté en message privé par
une casteuse qui m'a demandé si ça
m'intéresserait de participer au casting
je dit pourquoi pas et donc ça a
commencé comme ça et j'ai enchaîné à
chaque fois je me disais oui mais non de
toute façon c'est juste ça ça sera pas
pour moi enfin et puis à chaque fois je
passais les étapes jusqu'au moment où on
m'a dit que j'allais rentrer sous la
tente parce que vous faites de la
cuisine depuis très jeune mais à la base
votre profession vous c'est juriste
c'est un MU qui est quand même très
éloigné de la pâtisserie toutit tout à
fait oui je suis juriste j'ai fait des
études de droit bah Saint-Quentin donc à
l'université de Saint-Quentin dans le
dans le coin et mais j'ai toujours aimé
en effet faire à manger que ça soit le
salé le sucré et depuis plusieurs années
là c'est vrai que j'ai été vraiment axée
sur sur les gâteaux et en même temps
j'avais besoin de ce côté un peu créatif
où je pouvais laisser exprimer bah ce
que voilà ce que j'avais envie de faire
avec mes mains en fait et alors quand
vous avez su que vous étiez retenu pour
le meilleur pâtissier vous avez reçu un
message de Mercotte exactement
surprenant c'était très drôle en fait
justement la casseuse m'a fait une
petite une petite blague ça faisait des
mois he qu'on était je crois que ça a
duré 5 ou 6 mois le casting on attendait
et elle me dit écoute je t'envoie sur
WhatsApp on a un
dernier questionnaire regarde je viens
de te l'envoyer et donc en fait je
clique et c'était une vidéo de mercote
qui me disait que elle m'attendait sous
la tente et c'était parti pour
l'aventure c'était parti et vous lui
avez lancé un défi Gabriel réaliser une
recette à la fois simple mais élaborée
on pourra la retrouver la semaine
prochaine sur notre émission ou en
replay sur notre site Internet et nos
réseaux sociaux allez on ouvre à présent
une page loisir dans votre
[Musique]
78 et on ouvre cette page loisir avec
vos idées de sortie pour le weekend
Gabriel on commence avec un concert qui
aura lieu ce vendredi à Guill encs oui
et en tête d'affiche Mathilde le natif
de poissie Alexis HHK l'artiste au style
unique sera à la batterie de Guy encour
demain soir à 20h30 dans ce spectacle
l'artiste à la plume aiguisée jouera son
dernier album bobo playground un album
dans lequel il se moque des bobo et de
sa propre condition sociale de bourgeois
bohème nous l'avons interrogé sur son
spectacle il y a quelques jours on
l'écoute comme l'album c'est c'est un
assez bon mélange entre gravité et et
légèreté il y a beaucoup de coniv avec
le public euh beaucoup pas mal de rire
quand même parce que moi j'aime bien
mettre une partie pas standup mais un
petit peu amusante quoi un petit peu
amusante j'ai toujours eu un goût pour
les palabres interminables qui font
marrer les
gens donc il y a du rire il y a il y a
de la profondeur il y a de la gravité il
y a d'excellents musiciens ils sont
trois derrière moi basse basse guitare
clavier violon sel moi je fais de la
guitare ou pas euh et donc je je pense
que jusqu'à présent les gens qui ont vu
ce ce concert ont eu envie de d'y
revenir bon si vous avez envie d'y
revenir ou de découvrir rendez-vous à la
batterie vendredi soir à 20h30 des
places sont encore en vente et un autre
concert a lieu ce weekend dans les
ivelines mais cette fois plus sur désert
folk et country oui le court bouillon de
rambouiller vous propose samedi une
soirée country folk parmi les artistes
présents le groupe route 70 à entité
musicale pop rock et jazz manouche ainsi
que le groupe fabloup qui présentera son
premier REP hors du temps et je vous le
disais la soirée se passera au café
associatif et culturel le courbouillon
vous pourrez donc profiter d'un foot
truck et de plusieurs spécialités pour
la restauration on poursuit vos idées de
sortie avec un événement à morpa oui un
événement qui est devenu une tradition
chaque année à morpa le festival amateur
plein feu sur les planches s'achève ce
samedi pour la 9e année le festival mais
les comp compagnie locale de théâtre
amateur à l'honneur ce samedi c'est la
pièce le prénom d'Alexandre de la
patalière et Mathieu de la porte joué
par la compagnie d'interprétation
théâtrale de morpa le syè qui est
proposé aux spectateurs l'occasion pour
les artistes de présenter leur spectacle
dans des conditions professionnelles du
sport maintenant à quelques mois des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 le village à vous les jeux
entam sa tournée dans les communes oui
dans exactement 169 jours début les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 dont
une partie des épreuves se tiendront
vous le savez sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin en iveline à cette
occasion la communauté d'agglomération a
créé un village itinérant l'objectif
faire découvrir les épreuves les sites
de compétition ainsi que de célébration
alors plusieurs dates sont prévues à
travers les communes la première c'est
ce samedi à Montini le Bretonneux et on
termine avec une discipline qui ne sera
pas aux Jeux olympiques mais qui ne
reste pas moins impressionnante le
football améric vous donne rendez-vous
ce weekend dans les Yvelines oui
l'historique club des Templiers
d'élencour joue à domicile ce weekend il
rencontte les mermidon de Savini le
temple c'est le premier match à domicile
pour les hlan courtois le premier de la
saison ayant été annulé en raison du gel
et du froid après une dernière rencontre
marquée par une défaite les Templiers
veulent se rattraper avec un objectif
celui de monter d'ici la fin de la
saison et on espère qu'ils gagneront
leur match merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces idées de sortie
on poursuit cette page loisir avec un
autre événement les passionnés de jeux
avaient rendez-vous le weekend dernier à
Villepreux pour Festi jeux organisé par
la commune et l'association La Croisée
des Mondes ce dernier a une nouvelle
fois attiré les foules ce qui confirme
un retour à la mode du jeu depuis
quelques années les explications de
Grégory
canalé qu'il soit sur plateau en vidéo
ou même en réalité virtuelle le jeu sous
toutes ces Nuan et de plus en plus
plébiscité une tendance qui s'est
observée lors de la 9e édition de
festigieux à Villepreux plus de 4000
personnes sont venu au gymnase Alain
Mimoun les 3 et 4 février dernier soit
1000 de plus que l'année précédente
c'est vraiment une bonne occasion de
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes de
faire de nouvelles activités et juste de
trouver quelque chose de nouveau on
croise vraiment des gens d'un peu
partout c'est chouette ouais et puis on
fait découvrir ce qu'on fait aussi bonne
expérience on reviendra on refera
d'autres festivals de jeux comme ça
parce que c'était très chouette tour à
la mode du jeu se confirme auprès de
toutes les générations depuis quelques
années le monde du jeu en fait a
beaucoup évolué avec l'arrivée du covid
les gens ont commencé à jouer chez eux
et ont découvert le jeu qui se limitait
pas aux jeux de base qui sont ce que
connaît tout le monde le Monopoly la
bonne paye ou autre maintenant il y a
une quantité de jeux phénoménale et on
tout le monde peut y trouver son compte
petit comme grand je fais du jeu de rôle
depuis les années 90 on a eu un je dis
on a eu c'est pas moi spécialement mais
il y a eu un trou dans les années 2000
et ça c'est inversé depuis quelques
années et ouais il y a beaucoup plus de
joueurs un moment d'amusement et
d'échange le jeu permet aussi de
développer des compéten comme celle du
travail en équipe exemple avec ce jeu de
plateau c'est un jeu parfait pour
l'initiation sur le dungeon crawler les
joueurs interprètent un un héros qui va
devoir fouiller dans un donjon et et
combattre les monstres et réussir la
mission qui lui a été confiée c'est un
jeu de coopération donc ça force les
joueurs à jouer ensemble à interagir
ensemble et à compter les uns sur les
autres chacun chaque joueur a des
compétences qui qui sont différentes de
celles des autres donc c'est un c'est un
jeu vraiment bien pour pour apprendre à
travailler ensemble et les possibilités
ne manquent pas plus de 150 éditeurs
existent en France ces sociétés
fabriquent de plus en plus leurs produit
directement dans l'Hexagone c'est le cas
de ce jeu le jeu qu'on propose ici c'est
infiltré donc infiltré c'est un petit
jeu de bluff un petit jeu d'ambiance qui
se joue de de jusqu'à 12 joueurs et donc
c'est nous qui avons créé donc c'est
notre deuxième jeu qu'on a sorti juste
au moment du covid le jeu a encore de
belles heures devant lui près de 9
Français sur 10 se retrouverait
régulièrement autour de jeux de société
le chiffre d'affaires de leur vente a
même augmenté de 20 % en
2023 un autre jeu à présent mais un peu
différent connaissez-vous le
souousboutéo il s'agit d'un jeu de
plateau simulant un match de football 22
joueurs deux équipes un ballon mais les
participants jouent avec leur doigt à
l'aide de petite pichnette devenu une
véritable discipline discipline le
football de table à ses propres épreuves
le major de Paris se tenait le weekend
dernier à maison la fite Michel midoro
s'est rendu sur place 11 joueurs contre
11 montés sur des socles sphériques les
plus vieux d'entre vous connaissent sans
doute le subutéo aujourd'hui toujours à
la mode le football de table a même ses
fédérations et ses grands tournois
maison la fite accueiller le weekend
dernier l'un des grands schlem le major
de Paris mais le se buté au qu'est-ce
que c'est l'attaquant su celui qui est
en possession du ballon doit toucher la
balle à chaque fois chaque fois qu'il
touche le défenseur va pouvoir faire ce
qu'on appelle un coup de défense pour
freiner la progression il fait ce qu'il
veut avec son coup de défense mais il a
le droit de rien toucher ni le ballon ni
un partenaire ni un adversaire
l'attaquant peut jouer vite si
l'attaquant ne touche pas le ballon donc
le manque ou l'envoie à l'extérieur ou
sur un adversaire la possession change
demi-temps de 15 minutes avec des
prolongations en cas d'égalité un jeu
mélant dynamisme technique et tactique
200 joueurs une quinzaine de nations
européennes et de toutes catégories
étaient rassemblé pour l'un des plus
importants tournois mondiaux vive Italia
vive la Belgique une fois hein moi je
suis un purure purure pur attaquant donc
euh je suis une véritable trompette avec
mon gardien mais par contre en attaque
et un bon tireur 80 % qui se passe dans
la tête il y a 80 % de technique il y a
le sang froid le subutéo n'est dans les
années 40 de l'imagination de Peter
adolp une coupe d'Europe é crréée dès
1964 un jeu pour les 7 à 77 ans c'est un
peu les jeux de notre enfance he à
l'époque il y avait pas de console on
jouait au sousito on appelit ça ce que
j'aime bien c'est ben tout ce qui tout
ce qui se fait tactiquement le le
replacement je crois qu'après les jeunes
qui viennent sur mes stages et qui font
des des séances de de souousitéo on
envie de de s'amuser de de s'éclater la
ville de maison Lafite pourrait
accueillir chaque année cette épreuve la
France s'est portée candidate pour être
organisatrice de la Coupe du Monde 2026
et c'est bientôt l'heure de passer à
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de demain et du
weekend demain matin le temps sera
toujours aussi gris au-dessus des
Yvelines côté température il fera assez
doux compter environ 11°gr sur
l'ensemble du département l'après-midi
pas de grands changement les nuages
seront toujours bien présents au niveau
des températures il fera 14°gr à
manentel jolie 12 à Houdan et Versailles
et 11 à rambouiller pour les prévisions
météo de ce weekend samedi prévoyez des
averses dans les ivelines avec des
température d'environ 9 100°gr dimanche
la pluie devrait cesser de tomber sauf
dans le secteur de Houdan et il fera en
moyenne 8°g le matin et 10°gr
l'après-midi cela à présent de passer à
l'invité du
[Musique]
et l'invité du 78 ce soir c'est le
lieutenant colonel Sébastien Frémont
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le chef
du Group du groupement prévention
service d'incendie et de secours des
Yvelines avec vous on va parler d'un
fait qui devient de plus en plus
fréquent les trottinettes électriques
qui prennent feu c'est notamment dû aux
batteries en lithium de ces nouveaux
moyens de mobilité douce en décembre une
trottinette électrique branché au
secteur à prix feu dans un appartement
de Mantel jolie Sébastien fremmont
comment comment faire pour éviter ce
genre d'accident alors tout d'abord ce
qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que ces
appareils à à l'origine sont faits pour
fonctionner tout à fait normalement euh
le fait qu'il s'enflamme aussi euh
souvent ça résulte d'un
dysfonctionnement et en
général ça résulte du fait que les gens
vont acheter des batteries à moindre
coût pour remplacer la batterie
d'origine h sur des sites en ligne plus
ou moins sérieux où effectivement ils
vont trouver des batteries dont le prix
peut être divisé par 5 voire plus par
rapport à son prix d'origine et
malheureusement il y a pas de mystère
quand on achète quelque chose de moins
cher souvent la qualité est amoindrie
elle aussi à partir de là les composants
vont être de de mauvaise qualité ou en
tout cas de moins bonne qualité et on a
un risque d'emballement de des composant
de cette batterie un risque de
surchauffe qui peut être à l'origine
donc d'un départ d'incendie ça peut être
extrêmement violent il y a d'abord
parfois un phénomène d'explosion même
avec des
gèes voez d'accord il y avait des jet de
fumée très puissant qui sortent sous
pression de de la trottinette voire d'un
d'un
vélo avant de s'enflammer et d'enflammer
la totalité de ce qui peut se trouver à
proximité donc c'est extrêmement
dangereux ça peut être extr êement
dangereux est-ce que c'est uniquement dû
du coup à la surchauffe d'une batterie
ou est-ce que ça peut être dû à autre
chose ça peut être dû à plein de
facteurs en réalité alors ce qui est
étonnant j'ai des chiffres alors de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique en
l'occurrence sur la ville de New York
avec laquelle j'entretiens des relations
privilégiées en 2023 la ville de New
York a eu à connaître 267 incendies lié
à des batteries Lithium yion sur ces 267
incendies étrange enfin c'est c'est
quand mêmeel un chiffre inquiétant la
moitié d'entre eux résulte de batteries
qui se sont qui ont dysfonctionné alors
même qu'elle n'était pas branchée
qu'elle n'était pas en charge d'accord
donc la moitié de ces feux résulte de
batterie qui n'était absolument pas sur
le secteur comment ça peut s'expliquer
probablement des
chocs des batteries des trottinettes et
à forcierie les trottinettes que l'on
trouve en libre service probablement
qu'on en prend moins soin que lorsque
c'est la sienne
et si l'utilisateur d'avant voir
soi-même sans faire attention on a subi
un choc on a fait subir un choc à la
trotinet ça peut déformer la batterie et
ça peut être à l'origine d'un début
d'emballement du phénomène et donc de
surchauffe et donc d'un incendie et
alors selon vous il faudrait interdire
la vente de ces batteries bon marché
alors oui pas interdire bien sûr la
vente de ces appareils qui ont plein
d'autres avantages néanmoins pour autant
à mon avis il va fallir qu'on
s'interroge sur ces
sites souvent des sites
étrangers qui propose encore une fois
des batteries à moindre coût vraiment ce
qui est important de respecter c'est
d'utiliser le chargeur qui a été fourni
à l'origine avec l'appareil quand on l'a
acheté et d'utiliser des batteries qui
sont prévues pour aller avec cet
appareil la tentation est grande bien
sûr de se laisser aller acheter un
appareil à moindre coût mais il y a
vraiment un réel danger et pour
l'économie de quelques dizaines d'euros
parfois de centaines c'est parfois la
différence est importante on risque tout
simplement de mettre sa famille en
danger et on risque tout simplement de
mourir dans son domicile piégé par cet
emballement et cet incendie extrêmement
violent oui c'est un phénomène très
fréquent à New York vous l'avez dit dans
les ivelines c'est de plus en plus
fréquent vous avez de plus en plus
d'appel pour ce type d'accident en 2023
nous n'avons pas encore de statistiques
qui sont V vitablement aussi détaillé
que no nos collègues New Yorkais on y
travaille mais en 2023 ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que comme vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs en introduction on a
identifier au moins deux incendies à
Mantel jolie au mois de décembre dernier
et l'été 2023 un incendie survenu à
saincir l'école fort heureusement dans
les deux cas il s'agissait de trtinette
qui elle était branchée donc en en
charge sur le secteur heureusement le le
phénomène et le feu s'est produit en
milieu de journée un après-midi euh la
même chose la nuit assurément il y avait
des morts donc on a eu beaucoup de
chance si je puis dire même s'il y a eu
des dégâts matériels importants à
montelajolie l'appartement était
totalement détruit euh à sensè l'école
une partie du bâtiment et la toiture
s'est effondré donc c'est vraiment quand
je parlais de feu extrêmement puissant
et violent ça on est l'illustration euh
et vraiment il y a des messages de
prévention à passer mais j'imagine que
on va en parler tout de suite après
comment réag agir si on est confronté à
à des feux de de trottinette électrique
est-ce que on peut l'éteindre avec de
l'eau est-ce qu'il faut tout de suite
appeler les pompiers est-ce qu'il faut
partir pourrait pas l'éteindre d'accord
j'ai envie de dire avant même de se
poser la question qu'est-ce que comment
je dois réagir vis-à-vis d'un tel
incendie c'est comment je vais faire
pour éviter qu'il arrive éit pour se
faire il faut éviter absolument voir
proscrire de quand on rentre avec sa
trottinette à son domicile et qu'on
habite dans un appartement aujourd'hui
dehors il pleut euh la tentation est
grande de d'arrêter de se de poser sa
trottinette à l'entrée pour éviter de de
salir son appartement et du coup on va
brancher sur la prise de secteur la plus
proche son appareil pour le recharger
pendant la nuit grave erreur dans la
mesure où si la batterie dysfonctionne
vous allez vous piéger en fait dans
votre appartement et vous la seule façon
de vous échapper étant la porte de
sortie si la trotinette est est à
proximité avec ce feu extrêmement
puissant et très fumigène ben les gens
sont piégés à l'intérieur et risquent
tout simplement de mourir pour éviter ça
absolument ne jamais ne jamais vraiment
ni charger cette batterie ou cette
rotinette à l'intérieur surtout pas la
nuit quand les gens dorment c'est pour
ça aussi que je rappelle que la pose
d'un détecteur avertisseur autonome de
fumée détecteur de fumée incendi est
obligatoire donc tous les logements en
France euh et dans la mesure du possible
soit la charger en extérieur dans une
zone en plus de ça qui est totalement
dégagée avec pas de de de matière
combustible et inflammable à proximité
effectivement si vraiment on peut pas
faire autrement que le Fire à son
domicile surtout il faut que ça se passe
quand on est réveillé la journée et
surtout pas devant la seule sortie de
l'appartement et si on voit de la fumée
qui commence à sortir de de sa
trottinette électrique c'est déjà trop
tard en fait il faut déjà partir oui
c'est déjà trop tard c'est pas possible
d'imaginer de pouvoir
enrayer le phénomène c'est sont des feux
qui sont extrêmement compliqués à
éteindre y compris pour nous saort
pompier donc la seule chose à faire
c'est sortir encore une fois le plus
vite possible avant de que que les
fumées n'envahissent la totalité des
volumes de sa pièce ou de son
appartement surtout également bien
penser à fermer la porte derrière soi
combien d'incendie malheureusement se
propage par les escaliers par les
parties communes alors même que ils
auraient pu rester cantonnés dans dans
un dans un seul appartement c'est déjà
suffisamment dramatique en cela euh mais
vraiment penser à fermer les portes
derrière soi et puis bah bien sûr
composer le 18 et appeler les sapport
pompiers qui dans les ivelines ailleurs
aussi mais surtout dans les ivelines
interviennent très rapidement et bien
merci beaucoup lieutenant colonel
Sébastien Frémont d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je le rappelle vous êtes
le chef du groupement prévention au
service d'incendie et de secours des
Yvelines c'est la fin de cette émission
merci pour votre fidélité je vous
souhaite une belle soirée et un
excellent weekend sur tv78 prenez soin
de
[Musique]
vous